bien
[Música]
gracias por acompañarme una semana más
en medioambiente desde casa en france 24
la publicación la semana pasada de uno
de los informes de la onu sobre cambio
climático en el que los científicos
advertían de que el tiempo para frenar o
revertir los efectos del humano sobre el
planeta se está acabando llegó apenas
dos meses y medio antes de que inicie la
cumbre climática más importante del
mundo en glasgow la cop 26 durante este
evento los países tienen que poner sobre
la mesa sus planes de reducción de
emisiones conocidos por sus siglas en
inglés como ene efe o contribuciones
determinadas a nivel nacional y la
región de américa latina y el caribe es
una de las que más tiene que perder con
respecto al cambio climático ya que se
vería fuertemente impactada por los
efectos que implica este fenómeno como
por ejemplo la subida del nivel del mar
o la ampliación en la frecuencia e
intensidad de eventos extremos como
huracanes lluvias sequías olas de calor
e incendios para facilitar la lucha
conjunta de la región la coalición de
ciudades capitales de las américas
contra el cambio climático 1335 organic
a los foros de autoridades locales del
ambiente donde se incentiva esta
discusión climática continental su
tercera edición terminó de forma
presencial en ciudad de guatemala con la
asistencia de siete países
centroamericanos que forman el 20 por
ciento del bloque de las 35 ciudades
capitales del continente americano en
esta ocasión se estableció la agenda
ambiental común hemisférica y las metas
hacia la cob 26 de noviembre france24
entrevistó de manera conjunta al alcalde
de ciudad de guatemala ricardo quiñones
y ya será en palacio la alcaldesa de
belmopán capital de belice ambas
anfitrionas de los foros sur nacionales
de este año y del que viene
respectivamente
ellos nos explicaban por qué es
importante este esfuerzo ambiental de
las capitales americanas
las ciudades grandes o metrópolis
concentran la mayoría de la población es
en las ciudades donde hay mayor densidad
habitacional por metro cuadrado
es también donde hay más circulación de
vehículos más consumo energético hay más
generación de residuos y también por lo
mismo es donde suceden la mayor parte de
las emisiones de gases de tipo
invernadero
luego corresponde a que las ciudades
adoptemos las medidas de reducción
oportunas porque es nuestra
responsabilidad contribuir a la
contención del cambio climático del
cambio climático mundial habían visto
que las autoridades locales están en
contacto diario con las comunidades y
conociendo las realidades sean
científicas de la emergencia climática
estoy segurísima que podemos lograr las
medidas requeridas para mitigar los
cambios climáticos globales por ejemplo
a través de nuestros planes estratégicos
podemos hacer con los conciencia entre
las comunidades tales como reciclajes
sembrar árboles
con grupos juveniles
uso de materiales biodegradables
limpieza de ríos y varias fluviales en
cuanto al mensaje que como anfitriones
de estos foros regionales querrán
enviarle a los gobiernos nacionales e
internacionales durante la cumbre
climática de glasgow esto fue lo que nos
dijeron me mensajes que
estamos en un tiempo oportuno
vecino como un mundo que ya hoy en día a
través de la tecnología somos
se abre el sino como estamos cerca como
es como estamos mirando usted está en
frente de mí ahora puedo verte no hay
distancia
tenemos que hablar más
entonces se me da mucho gusto
a imaginar que un que una actividad tan
importante así que podemos llevarlo a
cabo nos ilusiona mucho poder contribuir
ser parte de un esfuerzo global y
especialmente poder tener la oportunidad
de compartir experiencias de aprender de
entender y sobre todo también de
escuchar y de ser escuchados es hoy más
que nunca un momento donde todos tenemos
que unirnos nuestros países nuestras
poblaciones no necesitan más
distanciamiento o enfrentamiento hoy
tenemos que unirnos alrededor de una
causa común y la causa común debe de ser
cabalmente este hogar común que
compartimos no sólo a nivel de un país o
una región es alrededor del mundo entero
del planeta estas discusiones regionales
continuarán de manera virtual con
representación de las 35 capitales
continentales el 24 de septiembre
durante la semana del clima de la onu en
ese momento se hará el envío a los
organizadores de la cumbre climática de
las naciones unidades en glasgow
declaración de santiago
el documento de compromisos ambientales
que hicieron las autoridades locales
americanas en 2020 y 2021 de esta manera
se hará oficial el plan climático de
referencia del continente y podrá
discutirse en noviembre durante este
evento internacional en escocia otra
fecha importante para el futuro
climático de las américas llegará el año
que viene con el próximo foro de
autoridades locales el cuarto que se
celebrará esta vez en belmopán la
capital beliceña sabiendo que el 80% de
la población en américa latina' vive en
las ciudades las decisiones ambientales
que éstas tomen definirán la viabilidad
de la vida urbana en el continente me
despido hasta la semana que viene pueden
ampliar esta y otras noticias
ambientales en france24 punto com